hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the tenth of April and you're tuned into
gamespot news let's get into it's our
first up graphics have not been letting
us down today the first example of which
is the gorgeous watch dogs pc trailer
the sun is shining kids are playing
catch aiden is standing around being
moody and gamers are breathing a sigh of
relief that the open-world game might be
just as pretty as we were hoping the
trailer came from ubisoft and in video
with the intention of showing off the
high-end graphics that those of you
lucky enough to have a beefy pc can't
expect to get out of the game UV
montreal and in video work together to
add the HPA o+ tech which is designed to
create more realistic shadows as well as
incorporate TX double-a anti-aliasing
effects in other watchdog me is worth
knowing about we've been getting even
more hints that the ps4 version will be
running at 1080p the latest suggestion
has come in the form of a video
interview which has since been set to
private but was seen by CVG where in UV
cinematics animation lead Lars Bond said
1080p is the plan for the ps4 although
he didn't give specifics on the Xbox one
in reference to the various platforms
Bond said at its core the game is the
same experience on current-gen and
next-gen consoles of course there are
nuances to it we're utilizing Xbox one
to its full capabilities and the same
with the ps4 of course so I know that as
far as to my knowledge on ps4 it will
run in full HD before we wrap on the
graphics type news for today it is well
worth your time to check out the trailer
for The Last of Us remastered on ps4 the
announcement trailer mainly focuses on
the fact that the hugely popular game
took home more than 200 Game of the Year
awards and it gives players a brief
glimpse as to what we can expect out of
the ps4 visuals take a look and let me
know if you're impressed or not just yet
lastly sony has a new game coming out
and it's got zombies in it so i guess
that trend is a dead yet if it's Undead
not only are there zombies but the game
entitled h1z1 is also massively
multiplayer and set in a
post-apocalyptic world so any online
president John Smedley tweeted that
gamers should be able to get their hands
on
titled soon the game takes place 15
years after the outbreak of the
fictional h1z1 virus and players will
need to face up against the infected
wild animals and other survivors so far
you can expect a sandbox game with
scavenging and crafting elements there's
also the addition of player owned
buildings the ability to light things on
fire and an in-game economy which is
likely to bring out a fairly interesting
diplomatic system of allies and enemies
let me know if you're at all interested
to pick this one up and what you reckon
the next craze is going to be once we're
done with zombies you can leave me your
thoughts in that comment section below
or on my twitter where i'm at just
mcdonald those are all the things that i
have to tell you about today but
tomorrow I've got my top five favorite
gaming news stories of the week so if
you need to get all caught up that'll be
the place to do it I'll see you then